but we are going to begin with the
breaking news a major crash overnight in
Maryland a pilot and a passenger rescued
after their plane somehow got tangled in
high voltage power lines and they were
stranded there for nearly seven hours at
one point tens of thousands of customers
were without electricity and schools in
the area were forced to close today
Scott McFarland has made his way to the
scene there in Maryland Scott what an
incredible day good morning
Tony good morning the fog Has Lifted
compared to what we saw here last night
but it was a grueling seven hours trying
to get the pilot and his passenger to
safety
it was a successful Midnight Hour Rescue
Mission in the dense fog Crews first had
to clamp power lines to remove any
threat of electrocution before they
gently maneuvered around the
transmission tower to bring down the
plane's pilot and one passenger the
single engine plane crashed into the
structure just miles from an air Park in
Montgomery County Maryland outside
Washington D.C to be up at
hot pretty frightening once rescued
one of the plane's occupants was greeted
by cheers before being wheeled to a
waiting ambulance both were taken to
local Trauma Centers after suffering
serious but not life-threatening
injuries including hypothermia police
identified the pilot as 65-year-old
Patrick Merkel of Washington DC and his
passenger a 66 year old Jan Williams of
Louisiana Merkel and Williams stayed in
touch with Rescuers during the ordeal
waving out the plane window and
communicating through the night by phone
we've seen the flashlight from the
bedroom window and I thought it was
lightning at first and then it just
heard the pow and then we came out here
and seen the plane the crash happened
during a rainy and foggy Sunday that
delayed commercial flights in the DC
area but it's unclear if that
contributed to the incident the
Collision knocked out power to more than
one hundred thousand customers in the
dec suburbs with most service being
restored by the morning never seen
anything like this before it's amazing
you know that they're okay
Hazmat crews are still here on the scene
trying to reconnect some of those power
lines as the FAA and NTSB begin their
investigations Gail
Scott McFarland I still can't get over
that video really glad to know that both
people are okay and the power is coming
back on good to see you too